[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
loisirs merci de nous retrouver pour
votre numéro dédié à vos idées sorties
tout de suite le sommaire de ce vendredi
23 mars
pénétrez dans un tombeau égyptien ou
récupérer des documents top secret jouer
les aventuriers et les détectives à
montigny le bretonneux un nouvel escape
game a ouvert ses portes cette semaine
mathieu bord de liart le responsable de
cette structure sera avec nous pour nous
présenter le concept des esquisses des
dessins inédits exposés à port royal des
champs le musée national accueille une
collection peu étudiée de dessin à
caractère religieux du xviie siècle un
voyage à vivre jusqu'en juillet plus
qu'un jour pour dévoiler sa flamme à sa
bien aimée emile est amoureux de louise
ne le sait pas et il va déménager donc
le temps presse pour lui dire un
spectacle à découvrir aux
clayes-sous-bois ce sera notre
rendez-vous junior premier week-end
d'ouverture du printemps pour le potager
du roi à versailles samedi et dimanche
des promenades patrimoniales sont
proposés dans le domaine le site
accueille notamment l'école nationale
supérieure du paysage
enseignants élèves jardinier est
responsable du potager bio du potager du
roi pardon partageront leur passion du
lieu avec les visiteurs et avis aux
sportifs prévoyez votre maillot de bain
et votre vtt ce dimanche épreuve de swim
bike and run à guyancourt une
compétition sur le modèle d'un triathlon
avec une épreuve de natation sur 400 m
et une épreuve de vtt course sur 10 km
aux étangs de la minière départ à 13h30
à la piscine andré pierre viénot un
événement solidaire les recettes seront
reversées à une association humanitaire
tous les bénéfices sont au profit d'une
association caritative qui s'appelle
pour un sourire d'enfant qui vient en
aide aux enfants en misère en grande
misère du cambodge
c'est une association qui existe depuis
une
vingtaine d'années maintenant depuis
2013 on a au total reverser 4500 euros
de mémoire a pour un sourire d'enfant
et puis cette année on ambitionne de
reverser à peu près 1000 euros on verra
en fonction du nombre de concurrents
[Musique]
agent d'élite en mission secrète vous
devez récupérer des documents ultra
sensible dans le coffre fort d'un
trafiquant russe
ce n'est pas le scénario d'un film deux
d'une bombe quoique mais le scénario
l'un des scénarios proposés par sky et
skype le nouvel skis et biesme de
montigny le bretonneux
il est ouvert ses portes jeudi 22 mars
son responsable mathieu bordeaux diarra
est avec nous bonjour bonjour alors
avant d'en dire plus sur votre nouvelle
structure on va déjà préciser ce qu'est
un risque abingworth grâce à un jeu
assez récent
le principe les joueurs sont enfermés
dans une salle et doivent trouver des
indices pour en sortir
absolument ça se pratique en général par
équipe par équipe de trois à six
personnes et vous avez 60 minutes pour
sortir d'une d'une salle en trouvant des
énigmes en résolvant des énigmes comment
les mécanismes qui vont permettre de
sortir de la pièce alors par exemple on
a peut-être pas tout dévoiler mais ça
peut être essayer de trouver une clé
déchiffrer des codes c'est un peu ça
l'idée par exemple
- en l'occurrence ça peut être de
récupérer des documents
ultraconfidentiels ça peut être de
dérober un tableau ou de trouver un
artefact qui est caché dans un tombeau
alors justement vous proposer trois
scénarios avec différents niveaux de
difficulté et donc du coût des paysages
différents aussi on se compare tour à
tour dans un tombeau égyptien d'un
trafiquant russe absolument tout à fait
donc g33 scénario donc les reliques
maudite qui est le scénario pour les
débutants ou gérer les non initiés qui
consiste à pénétrer dans un tombeau
suite à une malédiction
ensuite on à l'opération tournesol qui
consiste à voler un tableau en
l'occurrence des tournesols de vincent
van gogh pour le compte d'un riche
milliardaire français
qui est la salle la plus avancée on va
dire en termes de difficulté et puis on
a là une mission secrète dans un opéra
don qui consiste à récupérer des
documents confidentiels caché dans le
coffre fort du directeur du théâtre
national de saint pétersbourg qui est
aussi un trafiquant de drogue russe donc
là c'est plus pour les confirmés c'est
vrai sur le confiant mais absolument
tout à fait alors comment vous est venue
l'idée de lancer ce concept voir
absolument
j'en ai pratiqué j'en ai fait quelques
uns avant de me lancer
c'est comme ça que voilà je me suis dit
qu'il fallait que je joue ma propre
structure
en fait c'est venu parce que je
travaillais sur montigny et j'ai
découvert qu'il y avait pas de structure
pour pour sortir le soir de structures
de loisirs pour sortir le soir avec les
collègues ou avec les amis et puis à peu
près aux mêmes enjeux au même moment
pardon j'ai découvert le concept de 10
km et j'ai fait quelques recherches sur
sur le marché sur le concept voilà et je
me suis lancé comme ça vous avez trouvé
les locaux dont ces places claudel ans
et sa place que dell absolument tout à
fait à côté d'un pharmacie et vous avez
vous lu structure familiale parce que
les enfants aussi un sont accueillis
donc des dix ans et peuvent venir jouer
absolument alors
on accueille les enfants à partir de 10
ans accompagnés par un adulte c'est un
peu l'avantagé du concept c'est que on
est suivi tout au long de notre session
de jeu par games master qui va pouvoir
adapter on va dire sa façon de gérer la
cession s'il ya des enfants en bas âge
ce genre de choses donc effectivement on
accueilli en accueille tous les publics
que ce soit les enfants à partir de 10
ans mais aussi les entreprises les
particuliers les entreprises qui peuvent
venir chez nous alors justement comment
bien de personnes pourrait vous
accueillir lors d'une partie et comment
se déroule une partie
alors ça se joue par équipe de trois à
six personnes en dessous c'est on va
dire pour les gens qui ont vraiment
l'habitude de faire des escales games
est au dessus c'est un peu compliqué le
gameplay pas vraiment adapté et au
niveau du déroulé en fait vous arrive et
on vous brief donc on vous explique quel
va être votre mission ce qu'il faut
faire ce qu'il faut pas faire les règles
de sécurité
ensuite vous faites votre session de jeu
en étant suivi par un game masters qui
peut vous voir et vous entendre
et une fois au bout de 60 minutes alors
si vous avez réussi vous félicite
sinon ils vous laissent enfermer
une fois que vous avez une fois que
votre session de jeu terminé soit il
vous montre voilà où est ce que vous
avez péché et ils vous débrief on vous
demandera comment ça s'est passé
vous prenez une photo souvenir et après
on comprit personne parce que plus on
est nombreux plus on peut s'entraider
trouver des solutions mais aussi être en
accord les uns avec les autres donc
c'est aussi ça l'idée c'est un jeu qui
permet de développer le travail d'équipé
absolument c'est un peu la base de l'esc
et bim s'est développée la cohésion dans
un groupe c'est pour ça qu'on cible
aussi les entreprises qui peuvent venir
faire des tris building ou même des
sessions de recrutement parce que ça
permet voilà de voir qui va être leader
ou qui va être le suiveur mais le mieux
est effectivement c'est de faire ça avec
des gens avec qui on s'entend bien
ça a évité dispute alors dernière
question pour réserver sa partie alors
comment ça se passe alors vous pouvez
réserver directement sur sur le site
internet www.skyrecon.com merci beaucoup
mathieu quand il est revenu sur notre
plateau donc direction le site internet
de sky escape pour réserver votre
prochaine partie et retrouvez plus
d'information merci beaucoup merci à
vous ce sont des trésors inconnu du
grand public 53 dessins réalisés il ya
près de quatre cents ans aujourd'hui aux
archives du musée des beaux-arts de
bordeaux il s'expose à partir
d'aujourd'hui ce vendredi 23 mars au
musée national de port royal des champs
un reportage écrit par mélanie poker
[Musique]
une composition monumental un christ qui
s'en posent en premier plan le christ
devant hérode de georges l'allemand vous
accueille le regard accroché par le
raffinement des traits vous voyez un jeu
sur les visages dont le travail à la
plume et ensuite au la ville à qui est
vraiment très fin qui donne vie à
l'image avec très divin port royal des
champs plonge dans le secret celui d'
oeuvre jusqu'ici inconnu du grand public
une cinquantaine de dessins des
collections du musée des beaux-arts de
bordeaux on a vraiment des feuilles
incroyable qui commence vers 16 130 et
qui vont jusqu'en 10720 donc un 17e
siècle très large qui correspond au
règne de louis xiii et au règne de louis
xiv pour vraiment avoir des grandes
périodes du dessin française
de l'esc hisse au dessin abouti
plusieurs techniques sont rassemblés la
pierre noire privilégié au xvième siècle
permettant une grande rapidité ou la
plume lancre et le la vie l'exposition
se découvre de quatre manières on peut
apprendre tout un tas d'éléments sur la
manière dont le dessin est utilisé sur
le dessin sur la manière dont on
fabriquait le dessin sur l'usagé qu'on
en faisait ou encore sur les
représentations religieuses au 17e
rentrer dans l'exposition suivant 4 axes
à la fois la chronologie à la fois les
techniques à la fois les représentations
religieuses et également la manière dont
le dessin était utilisé par les artistes
le dessin religieux n'existait pas cette
époque mais le sujet pieux trouve sa
place dans le grand siècle port royal
des champs illustre son patrimoine
confessionnelles il en faut du courage
pour oser déclarer sa flamme
encore plus quand on est un enfant
mélanie le rendez-vous des juniors nous
fait rencontrer emile emile c'est un
jeune garçon amoureux de louise depuis
la maternelle très timide il n'ose pas
le lui dire
mais problème il n'a plus qu'un jour
pour lui avouer avant qu'il ne soit trop
tard et me laisser par envoûtant fait
bientôt déménager
et comme il est trop timide il fait demi
tour et en retournant en classe il
trouve une boîte bande annonce il était
une fois
1985 donc les enfants vous savez très
bien qu'ils n'avaient pas l'âge site
dix ans et moi 9 ans le buzz ça fait 19
dépêchez vous car bonjour tout le monde
bonjour monsieur maurice on allait voir
ma place j'ai trouvé une petite boîte
posée sur mon bureau je voulais juste
dire à emile j'espère que tu es chaud
pour ce soir moi je suis comme une
barrique
[Musique]
alors son histoire est à découvrir à
l'espace philippe noiret des
clayes-sous-bois christelle la
responsable nous donne quelques
informations supplémentaires
c'est un spectacle très original dont
samad ans a dans sa conception c'est un
concert live ya cinq musiciens sur scène
mais aussi une projection vidéo de
dessins animés avec des états de connu
qui ont prêté leur voix aux différents
personnages d'être connue donc pascal
légitimus ciranoé oldelaf quand peut-on
le voir ce spectacle
le dernier jour est à découvrir à samedi
31 mars à 17h donc aux clayes-sous-bois
et s'adresse aux enfants à partir de 6
ans et les places vont de 5 à 10 euros
et ce même week-end il ya une date curé
gourmand adore c'est pâques
et oui mais les cloches vous devrez
passer donc le 1er avril mais dans
certaines communes elles ont décidé de
prendre de l avance les gourmands élan
courtois qui ont jusqu'à 11 ans vont
pouvoir s'en donner à coeur joie
les lapins les poules et les oeufs en
chocolat vont se cacher au centre de
loisirs des quatre arbres à la grande
chasse sera lancée à 10h et préparez
donc vos paniers pour ramasser les oeufs
en espérant qu'on aura droit à un peu de
soleil un pour la chasse ce sera quand
même mieux
merci en tout cas mélanie on passe
maintenant à notre agenda
[Musique]
en boxe venez rencontrer champion
professionnel amateur olympique et
éducatif à plaisir les trois clubs du
bam les mureaux vernouillet plaisir
présentent leurs athlètes au palais des
sports ce vendredi à 19h vous pourrez
changer notamment avec elie konki
sélectionnés aux jo de rio en 2016 et
six fois champion de france
partez à la découverte des coulisses de
tv 78 le musée de la ville de saint
quentin en yvelines vous propose une
visite guidée de nos locaux pour
partager l'envers du décor ce samedi 24
mars
l'événement est gratuit mais inscription
obligatoire et enfin un match de gala de
football organisé au vélodrome national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
fondation caritative gol de letra créé
par raï et leonardo deux anciens joueurs
brésiliens de football fête ses 20 ans
un événement ouvert au public il entrait
de 5 euros sera au profit de la
fondation 7,8 loisirs est maintenant
terminé merci de nous avoir suivis je
vous retrouve vendredi prochain pour un
nouveau numéro et je vous
un excellent week end
[Musique]
oh